the majestic African elephant wild and
free but constantly under threat it's
estimated 20,000 are killed every year
to meet the global demand for ivory
ivory that has often smuggled to Asia
where desire for carvings and jewelry is
still high in an attempt to decimate
elephant poaching and the illegal ivory
trade the UK passed a law last year
banning almost all sales of antique
ivory pieces a law the government and
conservationists and are fighting to
defend I react sports from the UK is the
highest compared to any other country in
the world and what is even more
concerning is most of the ivory going
out of the UK is going to problem ivory
markets such as mainland China and Hong
Kong so the UK ivory Act tries to
address these loopholes and tries to fix
this problem and more broadly deal with
the problem of poaching and ivory
trafficking but antique dealers argue
their business does not fuel elephant
poaching and they want the law
overturned we're seeking a declaration
that the UK ivory act is unlawful under
EU law and the trade in pre 1947 worked
specimens which commonly known as
antiques has long been harmonized under
EU law and the UK didn't actually have
the power to depart from that
legislation because it's very important
that it's harmonized across the EU so
we're seeking a declaration today which
unfortunately would render the entire
ivory act invalid the UK ivory act still
hasn't been implemented and it won't be
until this case is complete currently
the European Union laws on ivory trade
are more relaxed and that's why this
case is being rushed through the courts
before the brexit deadline of October
31st but similar bans on ivory are being
introduced in other countries like New
Zealand Australia and Singapore
following the UK's example in the hope
that by removing ivory status as a
desirable commodity they can help
protect elephants for future generations
Charlie Angela al Jazeera and